Welcome everyone.
I'm delighted to introduce you to Jason Picard,
who is the Founding Assistant Professor of Vietnamese History and
Culture at VinUniversity in Hanoi, Vietnam.
In addition to hosting an MA from Cornell and a PhD in History from Berkeley,
Jason has lived and worked for extended periods in
Vietnam and is quite possibly more familiar with
the Vietnamese archives and the currents and trends of
Vietnamese history and historiography than any other scholar working today,
no matter the place.
I could say this based on experience.
Literally, every time I have a question about Vietnamese history,
I must apologize to Jason for this because he must think I sometimes,
whenever I have a question, I just reach out to him for an answer.
But especially every time I have a question about Vietnamese history,
especially 20th century political,
intellectual or social history,
Jason always has the answer.
When I say has the answer,
these aren't just off the cuff speculative answers,
the kind of thing that we all do when we're talking about academic ideas,
but they're always grounded fact-filled,
evidence-based answers that demonstrate
an intimate knowledge of literature in Vietnamese and in English,
in French, as well as source materials from the Vietnamese archives,
alternative archives, conversations he's had on the street,
people he knows,
other scholars that he can direct you to.
I mean, this is serious understanding and deep knowledge of Vietnamese history.
It's a real pleasure to have known Jason for
many years since he was doing his MA at Cornell.
It's been a real inspiration to just learn with him on this journey into Vietnam studies.
He's the author of some truly important works,
including Fertile Lands Await,
The Promises and Pitfalls of Directed Resettlement, 1954 through 1958.
Also Renegade the story of
South Vietnam's First National Opposition Newspaper, 1955 through 1958.
Both of those are in the Journal of Vietnamese Studies.
I also encourage you to really mine all of Jason's writing,
some of his book reviews will actually end
up as historiographical essays in their own right.
Also his MA thesis and PhD dissertation as well,
really remarkable works of scholarship.
Jason is currently completing a book manuscript entitled Fragmented Loyalties.
How Vietnam's great migration destabilized a nation and altered a war,
which examines the impact of one of
the most crucial events of the Vietnam's 20th century,
the migration of 1954 through 1955.
But please join me in welcoming Jason for today's talk,
Vietnam's Machiavelli Lê Đức Thọ and
his quest to shape the Communist Party of Vietnam. Jason.
Great. Erik, thank you so much.
That was quite a welcome.
Now I feel almost like I should just feel questions after that.
It's a real pleasure to be here despite the late hour in Vietnam.
I recognize some people out there.
It's great to see you.
It's been a very very long time.
There is a lot of material that I have to
cover and I'm obviously not going to cover it all.
I just wanted to start by discussing just briefly how I came to this topic.
About six years ago,
I had an opportunity,
after I had finished my dissertation to read
a book called The Winning Side, [inaudible] in Vietnamese.
I was struck by the character Lê Đức Thọ.
I think most of you will know the name Lê Đức Thọ
from the Paris Peace Conference with Henry Kissinger.
Tho was Kissinger's arch nemesis there.
Some of you may also know his name as the lone soul
who refused the Nobel Peace Prize back in 1973.
But by and large in the West,
that's about all that we know about him.
Recently some scholars have written more about this.
They've dealt in a bit more about his role in Vietnam;
his role in the Communist Party.
But by and large,
he is an enigma.
As I read this book,
as I said six or so years ago, it struck me.
The role that he had as
a seminal figure in the party was remarkable and yet very few people are aware of it.
The reason I say this,
the seminal role is because,
as you guys will see, his role was as the head for about 35 plus years.
The head of the Central Organization of the Communist Party of Vietnam.
Some of you may be familiar with old Soviet history, with Chinese history.
The Central Organization of the Communist Party was in all of these countries.
It was in charge of what's known as the nomenklatura,
and nomenklatura was basically the list of names.
It was the list of all of the party officials with all members.
We're talking in the case of Vietnam, millions of members.
This Central Organization Commission was in charge of employment,
moving people around, assigning people to jobs.
This might seem like a mundane task,
but it also meant that Lê Đức Thọ,
as the chief of this organization,
was also holding the levers of power.
As I thought about it more and more,
I realized, my goodness,
I know next to nothing about how power actually functions in the Vietnamese party.
In recent years, we've had some wonderful books.
I think many of you may be familiar with Dang's book on Ideology Within the Party,
which is a brilliant book.
I would recommend it to anyone and everyone.
[inaudible] recently published his book with Hawaii.
Again, a brilliant book and I would recommend it to everyone.
I'm still left, all these many years later,
many of you will recognize David Marr,
his book 1945, Quest for Power.
I'm still to this day left with the question of how
does power exists within the Communist Party?
What role do things like relationships play?
This is something, over the last few years,
has really aided me.
About a year or so ago,
I just started to play around with Lê Đức Thọ.
I started collecting some memoirs that I had found.
There are some very famous ones by [inaudible] and several other people,
[inaudible], and [inaudible].
Some of you may be familiar with them,
if not, not a big deal.
But anyway, I just got so wrapped up in this.
I pushed aside the other work I should be doing,
and I just decided I'm going to start delving into Lê Đức Thọ. Who he was?
What made him tick?
That was basically what I wanted to know.
As I came to learn more about the levels of power that he did
hold as the chief of this Central Organization Commission,
I realized the power that he wielded was in
so many ways enough that he was shaping the party and the direction it would cover,
even up to today,
which I'll discuss at the very end.
I won't have very much time,
but I'd like to conclude with a little discussion about
his role in shaping Doi Moi renovation 1986.
That's just how I got to Lê Đức Thọ.
I hope this is working. There we go.
As I said, all of you probably recognize this.
This is a very famous image of Lê Đức Thọ standing next to Henry Kissinger
in 1972/'73 with the signing of the Paris Peace Accords.
Obviously, he's quite famous for this.
Something else many of you may be familiar with is the works of Duong Thu Huong.
Duong Thu Huong is a Vietnamese novelist writer.
She lives in Paris.
No longer welcome in Vietnam, sadly.
But she's written many books about Vietnam obviously,
but in particular,
examining the Communist Party.
One of her more recent books,
The Zenith being [inaudible] in Vietnamese,
examines the Part B and her description of the Communist Party at the elite levels of
the very top is one that is extremely bleak.
But the reason I have this image of The Zenith,
and the reason I think it's so important that I mention this,
is that her depiction of Lê Đức Thọ is of particular interest here.
In this book, Lê Đức Thọ is weak.
She doesn't use the name Lê Đức Thọ,
she uses the name Sau.
Anh Sau Is actually Lê Đức Thọ's nickname within the party.
Anh Sau meaning brother number 6.
In this book, there is a figure Six,
who is in charge of the Central Organization Commission.
What makes her depiction of this so remarkable,
is that she reveal something that is whispered within Vietnam,
which is that Lê Đức Thọ did indeed try to have Ho Chi Minh murdered.
There's no evidence for this,
it's just something that sometimes whispered.
There is no evidence as I said for this,
but nonetheless, it's there in this novel.
For those people who are Vietnamese and who've read it,
it's stunning, Number 1.
But number 2, the description she gives,
which is that this man Sau orders the lights on Xylem airfield
shut off in the middle of the night as
Ho Chi Minh flight is arriving I cannot remember from where,
but arriving from somewhere trying to touch down,
the lights are turned off.
Fortunately, in this novel,
the pilot who's flying
the plane is a seasoned one and he is able to land the plane without trouble.
The reason I'm mentioning this is,
there is a host of literature.
We can talk about these unofficial histories,
novels, short stories,
and memoirs that depict Lê Đức Thọ as a brilliant organizer,
a man who played a very central role in the Communist Party for decades,
but who is ruthless and brutal,
and thought nothing but of himself.
Then there are the official histories.
The official histories depict a very different figure.
Yes, he's a strong figure,
brilliant organizer, but they'll depict ideas of this very resilient, revolutionary.
That's one quote, a brilliant organizer.
I'd love to read you a description of Lê Đức Thọ on the 100th anniversary of his birth,
this is in 2011 in the Communists review of Vietnam.
They wrote, comrade Lê Đức Thọ was a tireless revolutionary,
one of Ho Chi Minh's best students.
He was among the most important cadre of the August revolution,
and a leading revolutionary in the wars against the French and Americans.
In particular, he devoted
his revolutionary life to building the parties organization apparatus.
He's described as this brilliant negotiator,
the man who defeated,
who out-negotiated Henry Kissinger.
A man who survived the prisons of [inaudible].
These are a depictions of him as this luminary of the Communist Party.
This great figure who would not cow to the French,
who would never cow to the Americans,
and who led the way in terms of organizing the Communist party.
We have this dichotomy,
and of course in the West, yes,
we know about him as this great figure in Paris.
But beyond that, there's not really that much more known about him.
Anyway, what I really wanted to do today,
we have all of this stuff out there.
Differing ideas about who Lê Đức Thọ was,
and they all collect little bits of details here and there and they give their spin.
I just wanted to ask the question,
who the heck is this guy?
What makes him tick? How is it that he was able to amass so much power?
That's where I really want to work today.
My agenda, If We have time,
I'll try to get through some or all of this.
My agenda is really to think about him.
How did he become Lê Đức Thọ?
Second, wanted to think about him as a tiger in the South, which I'll get to.
Third, the architect of the organization.
We in the central organization of the Communist Party and in conclusion,
If I have some time,
I want to talk about how Tho was able to shape Đổi Mới renovation.
This image is an amazing image.
I'll get to it a moment,
we'll come back to it, but this is a remarkable image.
Anyway, the first section, becoming Lê Đức Thọ.
I want to think about his early years.
who was he? Where did he come from?
Lê Đức Thọ happened to be born in 1911 in Nam Dinh province in then north
into what we might term a middle-class Nam Dinh family.
Now, many official documents would say that he came from a peasant family. He did not.
His family could trace their heritage back to Hanoi.
I'll just put his name up here for all of you to see, it's relevant.
Phan Dinh Khai was his birth name.
Phan Dinh Khai was born in 1911,
as he said in Nam Dinh.
His grandfather was a failed mandarin.
He had passed two exams and then failed ultimately,
one of the city exams.
This would have been in the late 1800s.
He became an herbal medicinal doctor, pharmacist.
When Phan Dinh Khai was born in 1911,
10 years later he became Phan Dinh Khai's teacher.
He taught him for about two or three years until he passed away.
The thing that makes this so interesting,
is that when Phan Dinh Khai was born in 1911,
it means that by the 1920s he's a teen.
Not much is really happening when he is in his very early years,
but his teen years are extremely traumatic.
Both his grandfather and his father die within
a span of five years between 1923 and then 1928.
These two men were clearly up until that point,
the two most important figures in his life,
and their death really struck him.
What makes us all the more important is,
as these two deaths occur,
Lê Đức Thọ is living in Nam Dinh.
Many of you may know,
at this time in Vietnam,
in Indochina, there's a lot of seething feeling against the colonial regime.
There are uprisings and rebellions including at this place, Societe [inaudible].
This was one of the cotton factories,
one of the clothing factories in Nam Dinh,
in which Lê Đức Thọ had gone to work.
Now, by the time 1928 comes around,
Lê Đức Thọ has apparently,
according to official sources,
he's become a member of
the revolutionary youthly in Vietnam,
and a couple years later in 1930,
he allegedly, again,
these are official sources,
but he allegedly has become a founding member of the Indochinese Communist Party.
Again, we don't have other sources to back this up,
this is according to official backgrounds.
But nonetheless, he's involved.
He's clearly watching and very heavily influenced by these two things.
Number 1, the death of these very important men in his life,
and the other thing are the rebellions that are occurring across Indochina.
This is also a time where there are
the death of [inaudible] and also the arrest [inaudible],
two great heroes of Vietnamese nationalism of that period.
All of this we can imagine would have had a profound effect on top.
What I got to thinking was,
so this had this profound effect, but so what?
Well, as it turns out,
in 1930, Lê Đức Thọ happened to be at this site,
and it was on
the eve of the 13th anniversary of the Russian Revolution.
He's at the site along with some other friends,
and there is an explosion.
In the roundup that followed,
so this was around November 7th of 1930, during the roundup,
Lê Đức Thọ was among the 54 men,
I believe all men,
who were rounded up as suspects in the bombing.
He was confirmed at this point to be himself, a communist.
His family home was raided.
They discovered a great deal of paraphernalia,
that was Marxist,
and he was arrested.
The arrest, and the reason I showed you this image earlier,
this image is so evocative.
I love this picture.
When he was arrested in 1930,
this boy was 19 years old.
I first saw this image when I went to Kundo Island.
I don't remember when, it was a long time ago.
But anyway, this image is so evocative.
This is a 19-year-old boy.
I love just looking at his eyes, his face.
I would ask everyone to just peer into those eyes.
You get the sense that it looks like maybe some fear,
uncertainty about the future,
uncertainty about what knows,
but it's a really moving image.
Again, this is just a 19-year-old boy.
I think the first time I thought more about this image,
got me to thinking about Lê Đức Thọ is more than just this one-dimensional figure,
opposed to people standing in Paris next to Henry Kissinger,
but more just thinking about it and whenever I think of his politics,
whatever he did, but thinking about him as a human being.
Again, this is a young man who was just a teenager,
a late teen, but nonetheless a teenager.
Moving forward, he is going to be spending the next 5-6 years on Kundo Islands.
Kundo Island many of you will know it was a prison island,
very famous French prison island.
He spent 5-6 years there.
He was released in 1936 and he returned to Nam Dinh.
This was during the Popular Front.
They released many Vietnamese political prisoners.
He returned to Nam Dinh.
What makes this an interesting time in his life is he opens a bookshop there.
Now, the bookshop was a front,
again, for communist paraphernalia,
and also to organize the apparatus of the Communist Party in the region.
During this time, he became very acquainted with,
many of you may know the author
[inaudible] is most famous for writing a book called [inaudible].
At any rate, [inaudible] was actually the impetus,
the inspiration for this story.
[inaudible] came in Lê Đức Thọ's bookstore.
Lê Đức Thọ was working this bookstore and
[inaudible] came into the bookstore one day and they start to chat.
As it turns out, Lê Đức Thọ and [inaudible] were very familiar with each other because
one of Lê Đức Thọ's close prison mates
on Kundo Island was the younger brother of [inaudible].
At any rate, they became very acquainted and
this became a very important moment for both men.
This is an opportunity for Lê Đức Thọ to impress upon
[inaudible] the importance of class
and the importance of recognizing the international revolution,
and it really inspired [inaudible] three years afterwards,
and I want to move forward guys.
Three years afterward,
Lê Đức Thọ was arrested again.
This time, he was to spend the next three or four years in prison.
Among them was [inaudible],
many of you will know that place.
Then up in Sangla,
which is up in the mountains in Northwestern Vietnam.
While he was there,
he became how we might describe him,
the chief of party prison operations.
He was the head of the communist cell within the prison,
which led to a great deal of [inaudible].
Interaction with many people of many different backgrounds.
Through this interaction, and
I just want to leave it at this because we do need to move forward,
I think one of the things that we take away from the prison experience,
Number 1, it establishes his chops.
I think many of you will be familiar with Peter Cinnamon's work.
In which Peter Cinnamon highlights how important
the prison experience was to communist revolutionaries,
establishing their jobs as revolutionaries,
and then also the communists education that they would receive.
This was indeed a form of schooling.
The second thing that we see here,
is that Lê Đức Thọ
demonstrates a real capacity for organization.
Particularly in his second stint in prison,
he becomes the chief organizer within the prison walls.
In fact, he allegedly organizes a great prison break from the Con Dao Prison.
He himself does not escape but dozens of others do.
Actually, I think I have the book right here,
if any of you are interested.
This book just came out last year.
I think many of you can see this.
It's just [inaudible], the Sun Lab Prison communist cell.
It's a history of the prison and the communist party within it.
But it demonstrates a man who was a very capable organizer,
which I am going to show you in this next section.
Again, I know we don't have that much time and I don't
want to spend too much more time on this.
This is where we get to the meat.
When Lê Đức Thọ is released from prison in 1944, 1945,
remarkably enough despite the fact that
party histories tend to not discuss this very much,
he's actually grown to quite a significant figure within the communist party.
In fact, at the time of the 1st Indochina War in 1945-1946,
Lê Đức Thọ has become one of the closest advisers of Ho Chi Minh in the North.
Here, this is an image in 1947 of Truong Chinh on the left-hand side,
Ho Chi Minh obviously in the middle,
Vo Nguyen Giap sitting right next to Ho Chi Minh.
Between Ho Chi Minh and Vo Nguyen Giap is Lê Đức Thọ.
In fact, I love this picture because it almost looks like Ho Chi Minh,
Truong Chinh, and Vo Nguyen Giap had set up this photograph.
They were going to sit together and then Lê Đức Thọ rushed over to," Hey,
let me in guys. Come on, let me in".
These were actually three of
Ho Chi Minh's closest advisers at the beginning of the 1st Indochina War.
This is something actually written about by Ban To Chu in one of
his memories of the 1st Indochina War writing about Lê Đức Thọ.
He describes how Lê Đức Thọ was in fact,
at this point already the chief organizer of
the civil apparatus of
the communist party versus Vo Nguyen Giap who'd have been on the military side,
and Truong Chinh who's the chief ideolog.
But Lê Đức Thọ was already of
immense importance to the actual organization of the party system.
However, according to the memoirs that exist,
Truong Chinh and Lê Đức Thọ did not get along and they
often were found to be at odds with each other.
By 1947, '48,
the two men, Truong Chinh and Lê Đức Thọ,
were described as two tigers [inaudible].
They were described as two tigers ready to pounce on one another.
It was decided that they were going to have to be separated for the sake of the party.
Lê Đức Thọ, according to several memoirs,
had become a man with
a certain description by people like
[inaudible] and [inaudible] as a man who had a lust for power.
In fact, there's a comment in both [inaudible] and [inaudible] books
that allegedly Lê Đức Thọ would claim to some of his subordinates that he was the party.
He would say, [inaudible] "I am the party,
the party is me".
Now, of course,
these are memoirs, and they are unofficial,
and we have no other evidence for this other than what people recall.
Obviously, we know that memory is fickle.
But it is interesting nonetheless,
whatever the situation, whatever that was going on.
Nonetheless, in 1948,
Lê Đức Thọ is ordered to head South to
buttress and support the regional party apparatus in the South in the Mekong Delta.
Now, as best as we can tell,
Lê Đức Thọ was furious about having to leave
the North and having to leave the center of the action,
to leave where much of
the 1st Indochina War was occurring and where the seat
of power for the communist party at this stage still was.
However, this is a really important moment in
Lê Đức Thọ's life and also in the life of the party for several reasons.
But key here is that
despite the fact that Lê Đức Thọ might have been upset about being kicked southward,
about perhaps he might have seen this as expulsion,
which it probably was by being sent Southward and away from the central apparatus.
Nonetheless, this turned out to be a remarkable boom to him.
Because of this move to South,
a couple of things would happen.
Number 1, he would get to work with [inaudible],
who we'll talk about in a second.
Who would become later on the General Secretary of the Communist Party for over 26 years.
They would work very closely for decades.
The second thing was because he went southward in
1948 and he would stay there until 1955,
he became insulated from the disastrous land reform that occurred in 1953,
began in 1953 and it would run until 1956.
Because Lê Đức Thọ went southward in 1948,
he was going to have the opportunity to avoid all of the stench and
stain of land reform.
When he arrived South,
I know today some of you have maybe read some of these books
that have come out in recent years about the relationship between Lê Duẩn and Lê Đức Thọ.
When he arrives in 1948 allegedly there was a meeting between Lê Đức Thọ and Lê Duẩn.
A couple of scholars have discussed this at any rate.
According to law,
Lê Đức Thọ arrives in the South and he meets Lê Duẩn for the very first time.
Lê Duẩn is a dour figure,
doesn't smile a lot.
Later when Lê Đức Thọ meets him for the first time, the thought was,
the belief was Lê Đức Thọ was going to take over
the party apparatus in the South because that's what he was sent to do.
However, upon meeting Lê Duẩn,
according to these descriptions,
there have been several writers who've mentioned him and
I could discuss it at length later.
But upon meeting Lê Duẩn,
Lê Đức Thọ is so taken by the personality of Lê Duẩn.
He decides that it's best that if he steps back and becomes Lê Duẩn's subordinate.
This description is an interesting one,
but it's really not based in fact.
In fact, there's no possibility
that Lê Duẩn and Lê Đức Thọ were not familiar with each other.
Both of them were high-ranking party officials already, Number 1.
Number 2, both had been in prison on Condore island.
Whether or not they were in the same cell block,
perhaps they had not met each other,
but they were certainly familiar with each other.
The notion that Lê Đức Thọ would not have known
Lê Duẩn is really doubtful. That's number one.
But the next part,
the second part to this is,
why might he have given away power to Lê Duẩn?
Why might have he decided to become a subordinate?
Well, I would argue this and I believe this to have been the case.
Number 1, based on what I read of the documents that do exist and granted,
I need to admit here that I have not had
an opportunity to look at his personal files in the archives.
I've not been given permission,
something I would really like to do.
But what I surmise happens this,
he arrives in the South.
Lê Duẩn indeed is in charge of the regional apparatus there.
But Lê Đức Thọ was a smart man and he realized several things.
Number 1, he didn't have a foothold,
he didn't have a place in the South yet.
For him to take over,
the Southern Regional apparatus would have caused a great deal
of trouble with the local party apparatus there.
That's Number 1. Number 2,
Lê Đức Thọ was a really great organizer.
I believe what he thought was it would be better to work
from behind the throne rather than seated in it and I think that's what he did.
What I mean by this,
he arrives in the South,
he takes over the organizing of the party,
he leaves the leading of the party to Lê Duẩn in the South.
In so doing as the organizer,
and I should explain this,
several of the key aspects of organization within the party at this point is this.
Number 1, he's in charge of health care.
Number 2, as I said before,
he's in charge of moving party members around within the apparatus.
But Number 3,
another thing that he becomes in-charge of, is relationships.
Marriage relationships became one of his key jobs in the South.
One of the first people that he arranges a marriage for happens to be Lê Duẩn.
In 1949, Lê Duẩn meets a woman by the name of Nga.
He smitten with her and he actually mentioned Lê Đức Thọ that,
oh my goodness, I've met this woman and I think I would like to marry her.
Lê Duẩn already had a wife North,
put that aside and he decides he wants to marry a second wife.
Its Lê Đức Thọ who arranges this marriage.
In party history in Vietnam,
we don't really have much research done yet on this.
But it's interesting in Chinese studies,
there has been worked on,
on how the Communist Party of China used marriage as a tool to find party members,
allegiances to the party.
Because obviously as many of you may know,
this idea of arranged marriages,
the person who arranges a marriage is owed
a debt of gratitude from the people who are married.
This is the case here.
Lê Duẩn marriage is indeed arranged by Lê Đức Thọ.
Yes Lê Duẩn was the superior but
Lê Đức Thọ becomes the debtee,
he's the person that Lê Duẩn owes a great debt to.
Immediately upon this marriage and upon taking his places, the subordinate,
we immediately realize the evidence and the archive shows this is that Lê Duẩn
becomes almost completely trusting Lê Đức Thọ.
At one point, I think I have some notes here that I've loved to put.
Yes. Give me just a moment.
Yes. Indeed.
In 1950, a party secretary from Jilin comes to Le Duan and he complains.
He says, "Since Tho has come South,
comrades from all over come to speak with me.
I no longer see anyone talking to you."
Le Duan was completely surprised by this,
and he says to this provincial secretary, "What are you talking about?
That's nonsense.
Comrades lining up to meet with Tho is a good thing.
It indicates they trust the Central Committee.
What are you trying to imply by selling the name of Tho?"
It's remarkable what this actually shows.
It shows that Tho has ingratiated himself to Le Duan, number 1.
Number 2, it shows actually Lê Đức Thọ's recognition of how power works,
about how he can actually by standing a rank below,
by not being the absolute leader,
but by being a lieutenant,
he can actually control the flow of information,
which is what I argue he does subsequently when he becomes the Chief of
the Central Organization Commission beginning in 1955-56.
I think this is a really important moment.
For me as I was reading this,
I realized, my goodness,
the way power is working here.
We often think top-down,
but the way it's working here is it flows downward but then upward and the
amount of information that is flowing to Le Duan,
in this case, is determined by Lê Đức Thọ.
We would see this moving forward.
This is Tho and Le Duan around 1950.
In fact, this is the entire leadership of the Southern Regional Apparatus.
You see Le Duan is on the far left.
The man in the middle there in the white is Pham Hung who would later be prime minister,
and Lê Đức Thọ there right next to him on the right.
These are all the main members of the Southern Apparatus.
I would like to move us forward another image of these men.
But what I want to move over to is The Architect.
Lê Đức Thọ is an architect of organization in the DRV,
the Democratic Republic of Vietnam in the North,
his building of this organization.
Lê Đức Thọ spends these 6-7 years in the South from '48 to about 1955.
He returns North after the Geneva Accords.
Of course, as I mentioned to you,
his sole journey in the South would protect him from being
involved with this horrible land reform project that was clearly,
many of you may know,
turned out to be disastrous for of the Communist Party,
and it led to Ho Chi Minh and [inaudible] having to
apologize subsequently after 1956, 1957.
But Lê Đức Thọ,
he returns in 1955,
and several of the people who've been involved in land reform are demoted.
One of those who's demoted is a man who was
standing in as the Chief of the Central Organization Commission.
Upon his return to the North,
Lê Đức Thọ is handed that position.
Now, the job of the Central Organization Commission is fascinating.
As I mentioned to you,
he was in charge of the nomenklatura.
The nomenklatura is just list of names.
It's basically all the Communist Party members.
But Lê Đức Thọ really shaped this nomenklatura
and the Central Organization Commission in his own image.
There's been quite a bit of research done on
other Central Organization Commission's nomenclature in other communist countries.
Very little done in Vietnam.
But I love this image here.
You'll notice Lê Đức Thọ is standing in the front.
All of these people are members of the Central Organization Commission.
This was upon Lê Đức Thọ's return from Paris.
I think this was around March of 1973 maybe.
He had traveled on to the Soviet Union after that,
if I recall correctly.
Anyway, he's returned.
I love this image because it shows he's such a homely guy.
He's here with his family,
which are all these members of the Central Organization Commission.
This doesn't look like an office that should scare us.
This looks like an office.
They look like people you might like to have a cup of tea with, some coffee with.
There are young children in the front row,
there's a baby being held in the third row there.
This looks like a very familial oriented organization.
Well, one of the great things about this image,
it also is indicative of the way Lê Đức Thọ was able to feel loyalty of people.
Yes, he returns North, and yes,
he ascends to leadership of the Central Organization Commission,
but in so doing,
by 1956, '57,
he is charged with dealing with the rectification of errors.
The rectification of errors follows the land reform.
It involves returning many Communist Party members
who had been wronged during the land reform who are renovated,
they are brought back, and we're talking
thousands upon thousands of Communist Party members.
Well, it's Lê Đức Thọ who is charged with this.
One example of this is a great story,
many of you may be familiar with the very first person murdered during the land reform.
Her name is [inaudible].
She was this great, this wondrous figure.
I know guys. Give me just a couple of moments and I'll close out.
I have so much stuff and I apologize to all of you.
Anyway, he's the one who saves her two sons.
One son was injured during the First Indochina War.
The whole family was left with this big black mark on their background.
Their mother, [inaudible] had been labeled a great landlord.
This was a horrible label to hold.
The two young men who were actually soldiers,
her sons, suffered mightily because of it.
Upon his return, he was the one who went
to them and made sure that they were taken care of,
and that the family was renovated and restored.
[inaudible] had actually been a great help to the revolution,
she had housed Ho Chi Minh and
several other significant figures of the party during the First Indochina War,
only to be called a landlord later on,
and as I said, first person murdered during the land reform.
The point of me telling the story is,
it's later call who returns North towards the end of land reform,
and is the person who is renovating so many of
these figures who had suffered greatly because of land reform,
and returns them to their place in the party.
These people going forward have immense loyalty and immense feeling toward him.
What I'd like to highlight right here,
and I know I need to move forward,
just give me a moment, guys.
What I'd like to highlight here,
with respect to marriage,
[inaudible] recognize the power that he could garner over people by arranging marriages,
which he did many of including [inaudible].
This is a wonderful story.
In fact, what's remarkable,
he actually got a very derisive name, later called it.
The name was [inaudible].
I don't know how many of you are familiar with the tail of Gil,
but in it, the brothel owner,
her name is [inaudible] became known as [inaudible],
Brother 6, the brothel owner.
The reason they named him this was because he was known for arranging marriages and tris
between women of the South and most all of the Northern Communist Party leadership.
But anyway, this was a very derisive nickname, but nonetheless,
it suggests the power that he wielded over the Communist Party.
I think again, we know very little about
the personal relationships that men and women of the party had during this period.
What we see here is giving us a window onto that.
As I said, this is a way of wielding a great deal of power,
and obviously another way, in this way,
this ability to restore families to some form of normalcy and return them,
giving them a position within the party, within the government,
obviously would lend itself to giving Latex Hall
a great deal of support from all these thousands of people.
At any rate, he establishes,
he builds a central organization commission.
I just wanted to close with this.
He is able to build loyalty throughout the party by this time.
The Central Organization commissioned by 1960 is now in
charge of literally over a million people,
moving people around within the party, which is significant.
He's the person who decides where you go,
as the head of this organization,
he decides where you go.
Therefore, people are beholding to him, not the party.
He became the firewall for information.
This is an image of him in 1960.
Later on, by the Sixth Party Congress,
this is 1986, this is the Doi Moi Congress.
[inaudible] has gained so much power,
but people within the party,
[inaudible] have come to realize the figure that [inaudible],
or at least they've come to believe this to be what he is,
which is a Machiavellian figure.
This idea of Vietnam's Machiavelli comes from this period.
By the Sixth Party Congress,
[inaudible] is seen as figure who has only one thing in mind,
which is to move pieces around.
I'm sorry, I wish I had more time.
I would love to talk more about the Sixth Party Congress.
Maybe I can save it for Q&A right now,
but I know I'm already way past time.
Forgive me, Eric,
I apologize for talking so much.
I've left so much on the table,
all of you, please forgive me.
Jason, no need to apologize.
This gives me the opportunity to invite you back.
Oh, no.
I've been in rapture from the very moment you started telling this story.
It's really quite full of information, well-told.
To much I'm afraid,
I apologize to all of you
We'll bring you back. I think maybe we
can do another talk from the Sixth Party Congress on.
I would love to.
What I'd like to do now is open it up to Q&A.
If there's anyone who has to leave at the hour or pretty soon,
feel free to raise your hand first.
I'll withhold my own questions for a moment.
I want to make sure anyone who has an immediate question gets to go first.
Just use the reaction feature,
the raise hand function on Zoom and I'll call on you in order.
Coy. That's all right.
I see a note from Pam Coy.
Absolutely. Please feel free to reach out to me and I am available in Vietnam.
Coy, while you're here,
would you like to ask a question?
Thank you Professor Picard, this is Coy.
I was wondering how accessible the archives is
for these figures and any other figures.
Is there some censorship going?
I think that's quite a broader question.
Please feel free, differ that for next time.
What a great question. Thank you Coy.
That's great, that's a good start up.
I got actually very lucky and I probably should
have introduced this at the beginning of what as well.
I have a student who as it turns out her family is very closely related to [inaudible].
Their last name is [inaudible],
it used to be [inaudible].
The family actually changed it due to [inaudible].
At some point in the late '70s, early '80s,
it became, at least for this part of the family,
it become a badge of shame.
But anyway, I had met with several members in the family.
They were actually, I guess because she is a student of mine,
they were very forthcoming in sharing material with me.
However, your question Coy about the archives itself,
it is really hard to get information in the archives.
The personal information is almost impossible.
It requires a permission from the family,
not the family that I know,
but the direct relatives,
meaning his children, which I have not gotten.
In fact, I tried to meet with his daughter,
and that didn't go anywhere.
It's clear they're very sensitive about that.
So no, it's very hard.
But with that said, memoirs exist.
There's obviously a great deal of official history.
Then actually [inaudible] himself has left behind actually a treasure trove.
He himself did great deal of writing,
he was a poet, left behind a great deal of poetry.
You can actually use many newspapers,
dating all the way back to the 1930s and '40s, where he appears.
There is an avenue for gleaning quite a bit of information about him.
But no, much of the archives are still off limits.
But with that said,
I actually have invitation next week to visit the archives here in Hanoi,
which I'm really looking forward to.
I've been told that I'll be able to look
at some documents that may be relevant to my topic.
Jason, while people are thinking of questions.
I have several, but I want to start with one.
You mentioned, you end with him becoming a Machiavelli figure.
Obviously, you had more to say.
Yes.
What we got up until this point is actually
a pretty congenial figure using arranged marriages of
a pretty happy organizational life with
that office photo that you showed towards the end and those things.
In fact, many of the pictures two are quite striking,
especially the one in the south where they're standing on the bridge there.
The joyousness of the smiles that they have in those kinds of things.
I'm curious, how do you reconcile that side with the ruthless?
If you were to say, here's the ruthless side,
what would be the example or two examples that
really are undeniable and how do you reconcile that with that other side?
Well, number one. When I first came to this,
I want to admit that's a great question, Eric.
In fact that this is one of the things I struggled with.
When I came to it, I had already determined he was a Machiavellian figure.
That's what I knew. But as I started to do this project,
I became more and more sympathetic.
I don't want to say that. I certainly don't agree with a lot of things he did.
He clearly could be ruthless.
But I want to take you back to that first picture I showed,
the first image of him in prison.
It is a really telling photograph.
This is a 19-year-old,
who's clearly just been beaten.
As I said, you see some fear, some uncertainty,
not having ever lived through anything like that through what he experienced,
I can certainly say things that he did were wrong, evil, whatever.
But when you look at those eyes,
when you think about what he endured, prison to wars,
I think I have to admit the more and more I read,
the less and less I'm more inclined to put
a question mark next to Machiavelli or Machiavellian.
Because part of me thinks it's not that much different
than most other figures within the party at this time.
This was number one, life or death.
Second thing what we know about communism is it doesn't share power.
I think some of these,
I mentioned, he allegedly said something like,
I am the party, the party is me.
I think we need to look at when that came up.
If you wouldn't mind can I show you another image?
Sure. Again, I'm going to just go to this one.
There's this image. This is towards the end of their lives.
This is [inaudible] on the right,
in the middle is [inaudible].
Great figures. Remarkable figures.
I shouldn't say great, but remarkable figures.
This is at the end of their lives.
For many years, these three men had at
times been at odds with each other, hated each other.
Or maybe hates, not the right word,
but certainly had tremendous disagreements and were on
opposite sides of the spectrum as it were in during the war.
But towards the end of their lives,
they clearly, you can see it in this image,
they clearly have a real admiration for one another.
This photograph was taken in 1985.
This is the official photograph that often you see in books and in newspapers.
But that's not the actual original photograph. This one.
That's the original photograph.
It's these three men and in the back, it's Lê Đức Thọ.
Lê Đức, I love this photograph.
Because Lê Đức Thọ was often taken out of this image,
I love this photograph.
It tells us so much,
I think for so many,
especially in the 1970s and '80s to your questionnaire,
especially in the 1970s and '80s,
a lot of these figures,
the party itself was looking for scapegoats.
One of those would ultimately become Lê Đức Thọ.
Now, there is a lot of salacious material about what Lê Đức Thọ did.
Some of it probably was true.
For instance, many of you may be familiar,
but his role in the anti-party affair of the 1960s.
He is seen as the man who led
the charge on behalf of Lê Duẩn because Lê Duẩn was privy to this as well.
But because of Lê Đức Thọ's connection to
the organization commission and therefore his connection
to internal affairs and also the public security apparatus,
he is regarded as the man who really organized the anti-party affair.
That's number one. Number 2.
Many of you may already heard this story before.
Again, I want to be very clear here.
I don't have any evidence for this,
but one of the stories is that Lê Đức Thọ actually had Ho Chi Minh's wife,
his alleged wife murdered in 1957.
Again, these are salacious stories.
I do not know if that's true or not.
I want to be very clear here.
But these are the kinds of stories that come up.
I think to your point, Eric,
there are a host of stories I could tell you.
Whether or not they're true, I don't know.
The more I hear about,
the more I'm learning about Lê Đức Thọ.
Again, I'm really early instance.
The more and learn about him,
the more I become sympathetic about what he was doing.
He was clearly trying to organize a party.
I see there's plenty of things I would disagree with what he did.
He could be ruthless.
He definitely destroyed some people's lives.
I do see that. But I
want to be very careful about how we present this. I think it's important.
I've just recently been reading Steven Kotkin's biography of Stalin.
Even there, I mean,
he demonstrates a certain sensitivity.
I don't know if sympathy is the right word,
but certainly a certain sensitivity towards Stalin,
and as brutal and horrible as he wants.
I don't know if that helped Eric.
If you wanted me to go further.
Another question from David.
But I was just thinking as you're talking, I mean,
obviously you don't want to go down the path where everything's
centered around American Centric narrative.
But it seems to me that some of that double sidedness also appears with Henry Kissinger.
It might be interesting to read some biographies of him, [inaudible] comparative stuff.
But let me make sure that David can ask his question.
Yeah, absolutely. Go for it, David.
Go ahead, David.
Yes. Thank you, Jason Picard. That was wonderful.
That was just a very intriguing set of stories.
I want to just ask you a little bit about my newly interest in Ho Chi Minh.
I wondered if you could recommend a biography of
him in English and let me know if
there's other books that have not been translated that are better.
Well, wow.
Well, first of all, this isn't a biography.
I'm going to make a plug for one of
my-classmates of the University of California, Berkeley.
It's not a biography, but nonetheless,
Alec Holcomb's new book that just came out late last year.
This year is wonderful and he does speak to Ho Chi Minh quite a bit.
Alec is just a brilliant scholar,
so I would first recommend that.
The next thing. It's funny.
Recently, I'm trying to think of anything really new and
exciting that's come out in English about Ho Chi Minh.
I mean still the go-to book I think is unfortunately 20 years later,
William Duiker's book, Ho Chi Minh: A Life.
That's still the one book that people go to that literally covers his life.
Recently, I'm actually working on the translation.
I'm really excited because I've been having talks with verso about the translation.
But there's a book called The Winning Side,
it's by a journalist here in Vietnam, Huy Duc.
It's not specifically about Ho Chi Minh but it's about the Communist Party.
It's a history of the Communist Party since 1975,
but it does much more than just post-war history.
This covers the party since its inception and it has all of these figures in it.
Ho Chi Minh, [inaudible], Le Duan,
Chung Ching and it's a brilliant weaving together of
basically an entire history of the party since 1930.
It's truly remarkable.
He covers the end of the,
to Erik's point, not coming from a US perspective,
it starts with the collapse of the South,
from a communist perspective,
the arrival of the communists in the South and it moves from there
into things like re-education,
the boat people, Cambodia.
Doi Moi, and then it talks about the Constitution.
There's a chapter on the constitution that goes from 1946 all the way up to 2011.
There's another chapter on literature in Vietnam,
the impact of Doi Moi on literature.
In that chapter, he toggles all the way back to the 1950s.
It's brilliant the way he is able to bring in so many Vietnamese sources,
from literature to interviews with some of the most important figures in the government,
to archives, to newspapers,
to even like a folk tales that are like posts 1975,
folk sayings, folk tales, folk stories.
It's brilliant. It's really brilliant.
Anyway, I would urge you hang in there in another year,
I think we might have this book in translation.
Yes, that's right.
Yes, he did. Peter did translate that.
Yes to Erik Harms, that's right.
I would urge you to read Peter's review of the book,
The Winning Side it's called, David.
It's not yet out in English.
No, it's not. But you can go online.
You can actually read about it.
There's quite a bit written about it in English.
Great. Thank you.
Yes, absolutely.
David that's a really important question. You know why?
Yeah, biography man,
it's just not enough for Vietnam.
It's sad. Sorry. Erik,
did you have another question?
Yeah, I have another question.
I was really interested in this period in the South and you said that it ended in
'55 and then it made me think about your other work,
which you are working on the book manuscript which is about '54,
'55 and then that led me to think of a question I'd never thought to ask before,
but these party leaders who went to the South around
the period right before there was going to be this big migration south,
did they overlap and did they have a plan for what to do with all these
Catholics coming down and how to manipulate that whole situation?
I'm just curious he was there when the first migrants must have been coming.
I'm wondering if you learned anything about that connection or assistance to think of it.
Not specifically with relationship to [inaudible].
I have like 60 different memoirs relating
to alleged spies who went South in 1954,
'55 with those migrants to stir up trouble.
You mentioned one of my papers in which I talk about actually may not have mentioned,
but I wrote a paper that starts with
the great Pho scare of 1955.
In March of 1955,
there's a rumor that spreading all over Saigon in which allegedly
northern migrants are abducting young children to
harvest their bodies for meat that they're going to put in the Pho.
Sorry, forgive me everyone for giving such a description.
But this was quite serious.
It was in all of the newspapers in Saigon and in fact, at that point,
[inaudible] and the mayor of Saigon had to come out and allay people's fears.
You know, this wasn't true.
There is no evidence for this.
I have seen no evidence for this.
But this was clearly a roost that was cooked
up by communist spies,
but as I argue, there is clearly
something in the minds of Southerners that would allow them to believe that.
That's a question for another day.
But I have host of these memoirs of spies who come South in '54,
'55, and they are certainly causing trouble.
One other story and this is connected to Lê Đức Thọ which returns
North in early 1954 on a Polish ship,
the Kolinsky, I believe it's called.
Interestingly enough, a couple of weeks after he arrives in the North,
that ship returns South.
It's one of the few non-French and American ships to carry passengers South.
It returns South.
The manifest claims that it was supposed to have about 3,000 people aboard.
However, it arrives with almost 3,500 people aboard.
Because of that, the [inaudible] government sent all of these people to
Phuc walk and had them in detention for several months.
Clearly this was something that was drummed up by the communists in the North.
They did this, they knew what was going to happen.
They did this for a purpose and obviously,
as I said this was a Polish ship.
There may have been some involvement of international communism as well in that.
But beyond that, I can't say,
it's a really good question.
It's definitely one to look at.
There's 300 days of free passage that you're referring to as well.
It's a fascinating tale,
it's a fascinating story.